our son called for accountability it's
no coincidence in my opinion
that they put a gag order on him
and they put him in prison
the day before they had to appear
in front of senators and tomorrow in
front of congressmen
i think
i think that is fairly
an act of coward
cowardice
in their appearance on the angle last
night the parents of lieutenant
colonel stuart sheller
rattled the public consciousness
justifiably their emotions run the gamut
of fury and disbelief
can't talk to him they don't allow him
to make phone calls
we talked to him for two minutes on
monday morning when he asked us to
contact his attorney he got one phone
call we have had no communication with
him he needs our help
his family needs our help
and we're asking the american people to
write their congressmen and say if it's
not all right with them
then they want
we need you to say we want them to
resign
how can it be that a highly respected
17-year marine with multiple tours of
duty under his belt is sitting in the
brig tonight for saying the obvious last
month about our withdrawal from
afghanistan people are upset because
their senior leaders let them down and
none of them are raising their hands and
accepting accountability or saying we
messed this up now i'm not saying we've
got to be in the
in afghanistan forever but i am saying
did any of you throw your rank on the
table and say hey it's a bad idea to
evacuate bagram airfield the strategic
air barriers before we evacuate everyone
now by making those comments publicly
and then continuing to post comments on
social media some military law experts
are saying that the lieutenant colonel
likely among other things broke the
chain of command
well on saturday sheller posted on his
facebook that his superiors had ordered
him to stop posting on social media
he ended the post with
i'm ready for jail
then he was tossed into the brick
now if anyone is truly guilty of
breaking the chain of command or
disparaging the military it's general
mark milley
before and after the election he hops
scotched over the commander-in-chief to
coordinate with his chinese counterpart
and when nancy said donald trump was
crazy millie said he agreed
but
millie remains typically dismissive and
defiant
at no time
was i attempting to change or influence
the process
usurp authority
or insert myself in the chain of command
but i am expected i am required to give
my advice and ensure that the president
is fully informed on military matters
now who deserves to be held accountable
here a marine corps officer with a
stellar career yet still risked his
pension and benefits to tell the truth
about our competent military leadership
or milly the incompetent leader whose
own failure to speak out left 13
americans dead
they squawk about an insurrection a
three-hour insurrection on january 6th
but what do you call a general and other
officials trying to usurp the role of
our commander-in-chief because they
hated the actual commander-in-chief
seemed like house gop members were
watching last night because today they
confronted millie and defense secretary
austin and centcom commander mckenzie on
the blatant double standard
when people in the military like
lieutenant colonel stuart sheller stand
up and demand accountability when they
say that you all screwed up he ends up
in the brig
and you all end up in front of us the
american people want and deserve
accountability and we even have service
members like lieutenant colonel stuart
sheller being thrown in the brig for
suggesting that the public's faith in
our institutions continues to erode
precisely because everyone in the dc
bubble appears to have some sort of
immunity from the basic standards the
rest of america is expected to live by
for not
taking accountability we know that but
we're also never going to know how many
hours millie spent gabbing to the media
did you talk to bob woodard or robert
costa for their book peril
woodward yes cost or no did you talk to
carol leonik and philip rucker for their
book alone can i fix it yes did you talk
to michael bender for his book book is
frankly we did win this election the
inside story of how trump lost yes yes
and were you accurately represented in
these books i haven't read any of the
books
so i don't know
he was too busy reading abram kennedy
apparently
come on who believes he didn't read any
of the books even the pages where he was
mentioned he gave the interviews because
he wanted to burnish his own reputation
and protect his legacy for posterity
in these hearings millie austin mckenzie
they all look like football coaches on a
five-game losing streak
those generals aren't leading anyone to
victory
and i know that members of this
committee will have
questions on many things
such as why we turned over bagram
airfield that in my view
there wasn't there is no
was no risk-free
uh status quo
option
i did not see any tactical utility to
bagram
imagine what china thinks of the great
american war machine led by these men
not being able to secure an air base
long enough to do an orderly evacuation
forcing our troops to do impossible
perimeter security
with doing id checks with crowds
crushing toward them
well millie did admit the obvious that
the withdrawal was a strategic failure
you think but he still doesn't believe
anyone should be held accountable for it
and the pentagon has admitted they
mistakenly kill 10 civilians including
seven kids in that drone attack
same answer there no accountability
they might as well have just said are
bad
but of course no one resigned no one was
fired
it's simply stunning
by contrast sheller and his parents
accept that he broke the rules
even if his reasons were noble
while stewart broke the chain of the
command
i contend
general mackenzie general milley
secretary austin
they have broken the chain of trust
and confidence of the american people
and for that
they should be embarrassed they should
drop their rank they should drop the
rank and they should resign for that
the angle was the first to call for
those resignations more than a month ago
but today millie made clear it's not
going to happen
general milley will you now
resign i serve at the pleasure of the
president mr jackson
mr jackson
now for the alleged crime of demanding
accountability lieutenant colonel
sheller was stripped of his command and
thrown in the brig
his pre-trial hearing is set for
tomorrow
although he hasn't yet been formally
charged he could face charges of article
88 contempt toward officials article 90
willfully disobeying a superior
commission officer article 92 failure to
obey an order and article 133 conduct
unbecoming an officer and a gentleman
we'll see what happens
but all this smacks of political payback
doesn't it
an official attempt to silence and
intimidate dissidents within the ranks
if you remember your russian history if
you studied russian history you'll
recall what the soviets did to their
prisoners of conscience
the goal was to stop all dissent
by any means necessary
but we the people we have a say we can
speak out
they can't intimidate or silence all of
us they'll try but they can't
we need to stand up for those who are
brave enough to speak the hard truths
publicly
america has not been betrayed by
lieutenant colonel sheller
america was betrayed by our incompetent
arrogant and newly woke military
leadership
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else